Lara Croft's origins trilogy comes to a
close with shadow of the Tomb Raider
where she's now hunting down the
villainous organization known as Trinity
instead of piecing together their
motives and escaping their grasp shadow
doesn't stray too far from what you've
come to expect from this new era of Tomb
Raider though
beginning with the reboot in 2013 and
the follow-up rise of the Tomb Raider we
spent about four hours with shadow of
the Tomb Raider at a preview event and
while we hope some minor flaws would be
addressed this time around the best
parts of the series formula still shown
through
you can count on an action-adventure
game about seeking ancient relics to
bring you on a tour of exotic locations
the lush vegetation of Central and South
America makes for some wonderful
exploration through branching paths and
optional side-quests and makes the
process of discovery feel refreshing the
dense foliage affords some creative
approaches in combat like covering
yourself up in mud to blend in or using
overgrown vegetation as cover the
tropical setting isn't solely tourist
eye candy either one of the games early
hub areas a Peruvian village called
kawaki aku showcases the rough nature of
a small community holding itself
together and although the expansive hub
pie TT wasn't playable in the demo it's
promising that shadow of the Tomb Raider
feels a lot more vibrant with culture
and society as a large part of its world
building
[Music]
puzzles have been a highlight of Tomb
Raider and the clever solutions that
accompany them let you flex your mental
prowess
although the rewards don't seem too
gratifying the process of unraveling the
sequence of steps is the fun part the
fluidity and movement of combat is still
intact to slipping into cover at the
last second or lining up an arrow for a
kill just before getting spotted remains
satisfying however if either aspect
gives you too much trouble the game
allows you to tweak the difficulty of
combat puzzles and exploration
separately puzzle and exploration
difficulty in particular affect the
number of visual cues on screen while
combat difficulty affects enemy health
and damage and resource availability
unfortunately enemy behavior still
leaves a bit to be desired they'll often
walk into dubious situations that are
easy to exploit like a series of stealth
kills off the ledge of a boardwalk
although we expect the action to ramp up
there just wasn't enough to chew on in
the early stages patrol patterns and
enemy placement didn't offer much of a
challenge with many guards conveniently
having their backs turned to Lara
[Music]
close call moments have gotten pretty
stale and action-adventure games the
cliche of escaping death at the very
last second to keep up the intensity
would be fine if it were saved four key
moments but when they become so frequent
especially as a narrative device it gets
predictable shadow is filled with these
close calls even in the opening hours
and its effectiveness in ratcheting up
tension where it's thin even during
normal gameplay Lara will occasionally
slip while scaling walls or jumping to
ledges in which a QTE button prompt is
your savior thankfully an early ability
that costs once skill point gates this
altogether we had previously seen the
early chapter that takes place during
Day of the Dead festivities in Cozumel
Mexico which was part of the updated
demo after Lara swoops in on an ancient
artifact that's set to cause a
catastrophe a flood consumes the entire
village leaving several dead and many
more in a state of crisis although
Lara's companion Jonah's skulls are for
not even considering the situation at
hand the consequences of her actions
aren't really felt in that moment in the
context of a campaign where you're
essentially racking up a body count this
may not seem like a big deal but even a
hardened Lara might want to reflect on a
foreign towns destruction however it
remains to be seen how she'll
internalize these events and if this
will come back to haunt her as the story
progresses
those are a few of our thoughts after
getting an extensive hands-on with
shadow of the Tomb Raider if you've been
a fan of the franchise's new direction
this generation you'll be happy to know
that the formula remains strong but with
some lingering issues you can experience
it for yourself when shadow of the Tomb
Raider launches for PC Xbox one and ps4
on September 14th
[Music]
you